our focus is on the ground video citizen
journalism so for example we covered the
trucker Convoy in Canada very closely we
were really one of the few dissident
voices on the lockdowns and the vaccine
mandates it was very strict in Canada
the province of Quebec for example had
an actual curfew from 10 P.M to 5 a.m
every night whether you were vaxxed or
not sick or healthy a curfew the whole
city was under house arrest and every
political party supported this it was
United there was no opposition all of
our checks and balances failed so that's
a Canadian warning we love America
you're like our bigger brother and and
you sort of ignore us most of the time
which is the right approach it's not
that interesting up there but there's
been some bad stuff lately and I and I
know you're alert to these authorities
we're paying attention yeah and it comes
up especially with you know Trudeau
nobody likes that guy well someone must
because he got 33 percent of the vote
last time and with 33 percent he's been
able to run like a majority government